- Our next guests have been,
you've been with the
"Hunger Games" universe
for more than a decade,
she's produced every single film,
he's directed all except
for the very first one.
Let's welcome Nina Jacobson and
Francis Lawrence, everybody.
(audience cheering)
I mean, when you said kind of
bye at the end of the last,
did you think you'd be coming back?
- No, I mean, when we made,
you know, these movies,
it was a joy, honestly.
It was an incredible experience,
because we loved the books
so much and we got so close.
And so we really felt like it was over.
You know, it was bittersweet.
We felt proud and we felt we were done.
- And also, I would say,
Suzanne said she was done.
- Yeah.
- She'd been working
on the books, the movies, for 10 years,
she wanted to go off, do other things.
And four years later,
she called us up out of the
blue and said, "Guess what?
I'm almost done with a new book."
We're like, "What?"
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and she wouldn't
tell us what it was about.
She just said, "It's 64 years
before the first stories.
There's one major crossover character,"
who we could start to piece
together who that was gonna be,
"and that there's a huge
music element to it."
- [Kelly] Which I love.
- Yes.
- I mean, I love the original ones,
but I'm like way more,
and you've got music video
background as well.
- Yeah.
- I like we're both music world as well.
So there's a lot of
like, the style in here,
the way you were singing, Rachel,
first of all, is so beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Your vibrato is woo.
(audience cheering)
But I love how you go.
It's almost like singer-songwriter,
little country-folk in there.
Like, was this all planned?
That vibe, that sound?
- Yeah, I mean, you could probably attest
to this better than I can,
but Suzanne used to be
a country music DJ.
- [Francis] Yes.
- And so it was one of those things
that she's been so immersed in that world.
And, you know, District 12
geographically is North Carolina,
Appalachian, very southern.
So that music was very like
jug band, folksy country music,
and she had a clear
idea of what she wanted.
All of the songs, she had
actually written out the lyrics
in the book what she
wanted them to sound like.
- She told me I should
look at the Ken Burns country documentary.
- Oh God, it's so good!
- And it's amazing.
- Yeah.
- And it was in the pandemic,
so I had a lot of time on my hands.
So I watched all, I think, 16 hours.
But what I fell in love with was that era
from the '20s and the '30s
with the Carter Family,
and with Maybelle Carter, and all of that,
and "Wildwood Flower," and those songs.
And I think that's kind of the era
that she was really
pulling from when thinking
of these ballads and these songs
that were passed down through generations.
And one of the reasons Rachel
plays the big guitar too,
the big Gibson,
is we were basing that off
of Maybelle Carter's guitar
that she played.
- Oh, I love that
everything had purpose.
Oh, that's beautiful.
- Exactly.
Yeah, and then she just fit right in
and like got the tone
of it all so perfectly.
And then, what I will say that was amazing
is that she sang live every day.
(audience cheering)
- That's my next thing.
That is my next thing.
I heard that you did sing live,
and you're a singer, but I just...
People don't get that you
have to do those takes over,
and over, and over again.
Like, it's a lot to do that live.
And so that's incredible, not everybody...
I don't know many people that'll do that.
- I've never ever seen somebody do it.
Every take live.
- Yeah, that's incredible.
We have lots of "Hunger Games"
super fans in the audience,
and there's one I wanna point out,
our assistant associate producer, Olivia.
This is real, she actually
wrote an 8th grade paper
on how the "Hunger Games"
was adapted from the page to the screen.
She even interviewed Nina for it.
I mean, it's crazy.
- It moves me, honestly.
And to see somebody like Olivia
who was so inspired in 8th grade,
and then has held onto that
and brought it with her,
it really moves me.
It means a lot to me.
You know, we come to it as fans.
But I have a very special
place in my heart for the fans,
and to see people who grew up with it
and then turn out like
this is pretty exciting.
- I gotta ask you, how
did you do on your report?
- I promise, I was an A plus student.
I don't know what happened.
I think my teacher took off
a few points and I ended up
getting an A minus on it.
- What?
Let me see that.
Wait a second, let me see that.
- I love that you're
disappointed in an A minus.
- Well, I'm a little mad.
- My mother would've
thrown babies in the air.
(audience clapping)
- Let's see, where does the A
minus that you've been holding
onto since the 8th grade.
- A minus?
Wait a second, let me get this.
Scene two, hang on.
A plus.
- [Kelly] This matters more.
This matter more.
- It is A plus.
- With a circle!
With a circle.
We've got a bunch of super
fans as well in the audience,
locked and loaded with
questions for all of them.
So we're gonna start with Rachel.
Rachel, what do you wanna know?
- Hi, cast. (giggles)
I'm a huge fan of the "Hunger Games".
I have been since middle school.
In 8th grade, the first movie came out
and I actually convinced all my teachers
to take our whole grade
to go see it during class.
If the "Hunger Games"
was happening in 2023,
who do you think would be the sole victor?
And who do you think would
be the first cannon out?
- How do you not say Josh after that win?
- I would vote Josh victor.
And I would vote myself for first out.
(everyone laughing)
I'm so small.
- Singing's not gonna get
you very far in the games.
Well, though it gets you far in the games.
- Yeah, go see the movie and see
that singing does help.
- Spoiler alert.
- Well, I don't think that
if I was in that position,
my first thought would be
like, "I gotta drop some bars."
- "I gotta drop some bars." (laughs)
But are y'all competitive?
Hunter, you're competitive, right?
- I mean, yeah, I'm a Capricorn,
so I'd say yeah.
- Yeah!
You know what?
I vote Hunter, nevermind.
- What?
- Thank you, Rachel, and also
your outfit is super cute.
Let's move on to Rendy.
So what's your question, Rendy?
- Hello, cast.
Hi, Kelly, and filmmaking team.
Loved the "Hunger Games"
ever since middle school.
I did an entire interpretive
dance to "Safe & Sound,"
to commemorate the first movie's release,
in front of my entire middle school body.
I wanted to know if y'all
were into "Hunger Games"
and had to get sponsorship,
what would be the natural talent
you'd do to convince everyone?
- Well, I feel like mine's obvious,
'cause I do it in the
movie, but I guess I'd sing.
I could do a tap dance.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- And you tap.
- I'd get negative points.
- They'd take money.
- They'd take money back from me.
I don't know, what would you do?
What would you do?
- I always get complimented
on my whistle for some reason.
- He does have a really
good whistle though!
- Wait, are you one of the
people that can do this thing?
- Not at all, but I can do like a weird,
like, tweety bird, like melodic whistle.
- Do it, please.
- Oh, now I've gotta do it.
Don't I?
(Tom whistling)
- Oh, you've got the vibrato.
- Yeah, it's like some
weird, I don't know.
(audience clapping)
- Money, money, money.
- So much sponsorship.
What about you, Hunter?
Well, I don't know, I feel like,
I was gonna say draw,
but I saw Josh's drawings
and I'm like, "I'm out."
Like, he'd win, so I don't know.
- Now you just go intimidated
by the art that is Josh.
Well, obviously Josh would draw.
- I'd probably draw or I
would like, I don't know.
I freestyle rap.
(everyone laughing)
I would just try to find the camera
and look straight at the lens and like,
you know, give some looks.
- Charm the sponsor to death.
- See if I could just like...
- The side to side.
- I would try everything
under the sun, I don't know.
I'm double jointed.
I would move my thumb around like this.
- Oh yeah, his thumb is weird, yeah!
- Wait, do your arms do that too?
Oh.
- No, it's my thumbs.
Sometimes I just.
- It was impressive until, oh!
Oh my God, you look like Gumby.
- I hate it too.
Oh, I hate it.
- Ugh, on that note.
Okay, well, we need a commercial break.
But first, I've got, that grossed me out.
But first, I've got a little
surprise for everyone here.
Courtesy of our friends at IMAX,
everyone in the audience is going home
with a pair of tickets to see
"The "Hunger Games": The
Ballad of Songbirds & Snakes"!
(audience cheering)
We're gonna be right back with
What I'm Liking, everybody.